we're here at Stanford Medical School
with fourth-year medical student Morgan
theis and dr. Charles prober okay dr.
prober what are we going to talk about
today so Morgan I thought we'd talk
about bacterial meningitis in children
okay and what I'd like to do in
reflecting on bacterial meningitis is go
back to some lessons that we learned in
the prudent prescribing of antibiotics
a former video or prior video okay one
of the things that was mentioned as a
general principle in that particular
video was trying to understand where the
site of infection is in a child in order
to pick the right antibiotics and the
right management okay so in this case
because I'm referring to bacterial
meningitis the question might be what
would make you think that a child has
bacterial meningitis that is what are
the signs and symptoms of bacterial
meningitis so this is kind of thinking
about the site knowing that there's an
infection in the cerebrospinal fluid or
fluid around the brain and spinal cord
you have to look for that in a variety
of ways as a doctor exactly and one of
the things which will make you which
wake a physician suspicious that there
may be an infection in the cerebral
spinal fluid or that is in the central
nervous system is a child may not be
behaving normally that is they'll have
an altered state of consciousness
they'll be very very sleepy or they'll
be very irritable okay
so the I guess I would say the signs
here irritable children and what was the
other one you said and I mentioned they
might be very sleepy some people might
use the word lethargic as a altered
state of consciousness and at the
extreme of that the child would be in
coma but that would be more advanced in
the infection okay and then the child
would almost invariably have a fever
associated with it will this illness
and on examination when the physician
examines a child they may detect what
are called meningeal signs and those
meningeal signs include a stiff neck
especially if the child's over one or
two years of age and how can you tell if
someone has a stiff neck so what the
physician will often do is hold the
child behind the head and try to flex
the head on the neck try to flex the
neck and stiff would be literally that
that the child's neck would not Bend
when the head is elevated from the bed
oh wow so it just stays really like
linear you know you can't really curve
it well exactly the other meningeal
signs that may be present in addition to
the stiff neck are the child may have
some seizures abnormal movements okay
the child might also assume an abnormal
posture a stiffening of the body so not
just the neck being stiff but the rest
of the body being stiff as well and on
examination of the neurologic system the
nervous system the child may have would
have referred to as focal signs that is
asymmetry between the two sides of the
body oh and what kinds of things would
you see that were a symmetrical it could
be that one side of the body is weaker
than the other it could be that one side
of the body has different reflexes and
the other side of the body so these are
all signs and symptoms that may be
associated with bacterial meningitis
that would make this the physician
suspicious of the diagnosis of
meningitis okay so we talked about some
of the things you look for as a doctor
now just going back a minute you said
we're talking about bacterial meningitis
does that assume that there's other
types of meningitis that we're not
addressing in this lecture that's a very
important point so I am focusing on
bacterial meningitis there are other
types of organisms that is non bacteria
that can cause meningitis and the most
prominent of those other organisms are
viruses so you can have a viral
meningitis okay sometimes referred to as
aseptic meningitis
and that in fact is more common than
bacterial meningitis so it's very
important to consider okay
there are also some parasites that can
cause meningitis and there's some fungi
that can cause meningitis the fungi and
parasites are uncommon in the general
population but they may occur in
patients who have an abnormal immune
system okay
viral meningitis on the other hand is
really as I mentioned quite common okay
but for today I'm focusing on bacterial
meningitis so you suspect that the
infection may be present based upon
those signs and symptoms that we've
spoken about and then to prove or
determine whether or not meningitis is
present a cerebral spinal fluid
examination or cerebrospinal fluid has
to be examined and cerebral spinal fluid
which is typically abbreviated CSF is
EPS it stands for cerebral spinal fluid
we already got that but okay
sorry and that's obtained by doing
something called a lumbar puncture by
putting a needle in the back to obtain
fluid okay
um is that also what a spinal tap is and
that's also called a spinal tap exactly
the lumbar puncture or spinal tap when
that's obtained using a needle into the
lumbar area the fluid is then sent to
the laboratory who will examine the
fluid in in different ways okay one is
to look under the microscope and
determine if there are an abnormal
number of white blood cells present so
abnormal meaning high or low I mean just
okay the normal number of white blood
cells in the CSF is zero so high is
something greater than zero okay and
with bacterial meningitis it tends to be
really quite high one or two thousand or
more than that okay with viral
meningitis it may not be quite as high
and that's person unit of volume of this
fluid exactly a glucose concentration is
also measured when the fluid is sent to
the lab
and with bacterial meningitis the
glucose in this mono fluid tends to be
low less than 40 now why would it be low
it's low because with meningitis you
have an abnormal penetrability or lack
of penetrability of the meninges which
are the coverings of the brain reducing
the amount of glucose that's transported
into the spinal fluid okay and then most
importantly the fluid is examined with
something called a Gram stain a special
kind of stain it's Graham with a capital
G named after dr. Graham and a Gram
stain can determine whether or not there
are bacteria present okay so you're
actually staining the bacteria exactly
and if there are sufficient bacteria
present the Gram stain will reveal those
bacteria okay and so with bacterial
meningitis they're the second principal
prudent principal is to know the usual
pathogen so if a spinal fluid is
obtained there are lots of white cells
the glucose is low even with a negative
Gram stain one can guess the usual
pathogens because the list is short in
normal children and those bacteria the
short list includes a bacteria called
hemolysis influenza type B a second
bacteria and an that I'm going to eat at
the end is an e on the end a second
bacteria is the pneumococcus now that's
funny it sounds like it causes pneumonia
and it does indeed cause pneumonia as
well but it also causes bacterial
meningitis okay
and a third bacteria is called
meningococcal and that's those are the
prominent bacteria in normal children
with bacterial meningitis the reason
though we're not seeing as much
bacterial meningitis in 2011 as we were
seeing 10 and 20 years ago is we now
have vaccination against each of those
three different pathogens all of them we
do we vaccinate against a marvelous
influenza
be starting at two months of age and by
the time the child is about a year and a
half they're completely protected
against that particular bacteria okay
the pneumococcus we also vaccinate
against and it's very successful the
vaccine is very successful at reducing
the frequency of pneumococcal meningitis
it also starts at two months of age okay
and the ninja caucus is the vaccine is
relatively new and is used in children
who are a bit older there are over two
years of age under special circumstances
so that means that we still can see and
do see cases of meningococcal meningitis
because occurs in children under two
years of age I see but those are the
usual pathogens and when you go to other
parts of the world who don't use
vaccines those are the pathogens that
will be prominent in causing bacterial
meningitis and knowing those pathogens
we go to the third principle of
antibiotic prescribing which is knowing
what that what antibiotics typically
kill those bacteria okay so what should
I call that category like and that's
that's catching pathogen sensitivity
knowing what what antibiotics work
against the likely bug so pathogen
sensitivity okay great sensitivity to
the antibiotics and and that I think you
were mentioning in your last lecture
that varies by the location in the body
and the location in the world that
you're using the antibiotic is that
right I had varies according to the
location in the world but not not a nod
on what part of the body they're in okay
and fortunately for the treatment of
bacterial meningitis to cover all three
of the bacteria that are on the list of
pathogens to antibiotics cover all three
of them and I'll just mention their
names and as I end this one antibiotic
is cefotaxime and a reasonable facsimile
of cefotaxime is ceftriaxone and they're
very similar antibiotic so we give one
or the other of those two antibiotics
okay and because some of the pneumococci
are resistant to so-called beta lactam
drug
penicillin and cephalosporins vancomycin
also is used to initiate therapy for
suspected bacterial meningitis okay so
we use vancomycin if we think you have a
sort of resistant bugs bugs that are
resistant to the first two antibiotics
you mentioned exactly and there's some
kind of lab tests you might be able to
do to find that out exactly so those are
the the principles of antibiotic
prescribing in terms of the diagnosis of
bacterial meningitis knowing the site of
infection that is a spinal fluid knowing
how to diagnose it what the pathogens
are and what antibiotics would work
against those pathogens at that site of
infection okay and just my last question
is just because we've learned a lot
about how there's a tight barrier
between the blood and the cerebrospinal
fluid are these antibiotics that you've
listed here those able to sort of
penetrate through that barrier and get
into the cerebrospinal fluid
an extraordinarily important question
which back to another principle of
antibiotics which is you have to make
sure that it can be delivered to the
suspected site of infection and for
those particular antibiotics the answer
is yes okay thank you so much